[Music]
on Kiev Central maidan Square just
before noon an air raid alert
it's the sound of explosions
air defense streaking through the sky
some people ran for cover taking shelter
in a shopping center and metro station
some looked scared nervous about what
would happen next
yes yes we we come here to to be safe
explosions in there
it's our Air Defense Forces so they are
working good
the fear does accumulate but what can we
do until we defeat the enemy we will
have to be patient keep is more
protected so maybe it's not quite as
scary as other cities
well the air raid alert is ongoing so
many people still here in the Metro
station taking shelter a lot of them
very shaken because this is the first
daytime attack in Keith in several weeks
Ukrainian military officials say they
shot down cruise and ballistic missiles
launched by Russia
today I talked to ask of his boss is
missiles
debris fell in some parts of the city
but keeves mayor says that no one was
killed
the air raid came after another night of
Russian missile and drone attacks the
15th and Kiev since the start of May
[Music]
daytime raid is a frightening reminder
for people in the city of similar
attacks last year and could signal a new
phase in the war
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Kiev
uganda's president has signed a new bill
into law that allows the death penalty
for so